[Music]
well welcome back to unsensed I'm joined
Now by Sam Harris one of the world's
great thinkers Sam I know you were
listening to that debate I just had
about Free Speech where do you sit on on
that and in particular Elon musk's
reversal of his decision to keep Alex
Jones off the platform
X well I think we're we're pretty
confused on this particular point I
think much that is said about free
speech espe in America doesn't really
have to do with free speech when you're
talking about these platforms for
instance these platforms have to be
moderated it's just it's not a it's
never a question it's never been a
question of anything like quote free
speech absolutism on these platforms if
if they're not moderated if you're not
cleaning up some of the toxicity X or
Facebook or any of these other you know
mainstream platforms would be like 4chan
or achan right I it would just be a a
completely you know sociopathic
free-for-all um nobody wants that nobody
would tolerate that certainly
advertisers wouldn't spend any money to
be next to that so you know as much as
people call him a a free speech
absolutist and he even calls himself
that that's that's never been in the
cards and he's banned people as you know
for a wide variety of idiosyncratic
reasons and then he's brought Alex Jones
back saying that he would never do that
uh and um I think it's a mistake I think
Alex Jones is a genuinely bad actor I
think he he um monetized the misery of
the Sandy Hook parent in a way that's
truly unconscionable and unforgivable
and while he says he's apologized he
hasn't quite apologized for that at
least not to in my hearing no um you
know so he's he's um yeah I just think I
think once you admit that these even
even these public companies are uh
platforms that are not analogous to the
Public Square right they have to you
can't simply use the first amendment in
the US and say anything that's legal can
be said here right because then it's
just it becomes a business that that
that is guaranteed to fail so they're
businesses right and I think I also
think that the the you know hearing step
Crowder try to say that well you know
for all we know you implied Alex Jones
would have believed that Sandy Hook was
fake nobody thinks that Alex Jones knew
it wasn't staged Steven Crowder knows
that Alex Jones knew it wasn't staged we
all do he deliberately flew with that
conspiracy theory to generate vast
amounts of of wealth for himself several
hundred million dollars came off the
back yeah purely of the reaction to that
conspiracy theory that's why he did it
um so there's a disingenuousness at the
heart of that of people who defend him
over whether he believed it on no one no
one with a brain thinks he believed
it yeah yeah well even if you're
agnostic as to what he believed the
effects of his actions were so
intolerable I mean there there are Sandy
Hook parents that have moved 10 times
yeah since he went berserk in their
direction right and he and he knew his
fans very early on he knew what the
consequences of his actions were
whatever he believed yeah they were
being harassed in the street one one
poor man said at one of the cases uh
that his son's grave had been urinated
on as a direct result of what Alex Jones
was saying on air and that just may it
maybe me want to cry actually it was
just horrific um let's turn to why why
you actually came on tonight we had an
interesting debate last night involving
several people one was masab ham yev
he's the son of one of the Hamas
co-founders who then renounced Hamas and
moved away um and you said this about
what's going on at the moment in the
Israel Gaza War let's take a
listen any person who put the religious
identity above the highest interest of
humanity I have no respect for this
people the majority of the musl Muslim
people identified with Hamas supported
Hamas show me how many Muslims out there
who condemned Hamas genocide what was
interesting about that is that he was
really suggesting that the motivating
factor behind that what Hamas did and
why people are supporting them in such
big numbers in the Muslim Community it's
because they're Muslims it's religion
driven now you're an atheist but what
you think of that uh of this idea that
it's actually really about
religion well I'm going to agree with
him I think it's interesting to to note
that many of your listeners will doubt
my ability to to make the the statements
of of A Sort I'm now going to make but
they can't doubt that of him right I
mean he obviously knows whereof he
speaks right you can't play the identity
politics game with him and say that you
know he doesn't understand the culture
he's the wrong skin color he doesn't
speak the language etc etc so let's just
just let's C you know flag that that
particular uh qualm with what I'm going
to say what I'm going to say it should
just be obvious to everyone which is
that we have a vast number of people in
the Muslim Community worldwide not just
in the occupied territories or in Gaza
who are powerfully deranged by religious
symbols and and their religious identity
which is to say it is the most important
thing to them but but more important
even than the deaths of their own
children right we're talking about a
culture again I'm I'm not talking about
just Palestinians I'm talking about the
Muslim Community worldwide you know in
dozens of countries that has produced a
seemingly unending supply of suicide
bombers over the last 50 years right
where we're talking about societies
where phenomenon that should be
impossible are are are are simply to be
expected I literally like rigging
children to to explode just that me
think of how deranging that is for an
army or a police force or an NGO or
anyone to have to imagine that a child
isn't simply a child but a child might
in fact under certain circumstances be a
bomb right I mean that that is the
situation we're in we're talking about a
society and now now I'm talking about
the the Gaza and the West Bank in
particular where in their schools they
teach six-year-olds the love of
martyrdom the literal aspiration to die
as a martyr and the hatred of Jews and
and many of these schools are un funded
right so this is
a a um a terrifying situation which the
world has simply acquiesced to I mean
the world on some level has simply
accepted that there is a a different
standard held to the Muslim Community
right we all understand that you can
stage a play making fun of Mormonism on
Broadway and it can become the biggest
musical in the United States The Book of
Mormon um but to stage of such a play
about Islam would be Unthinkable and to
be Unthinkable not because the first
amendment doesn't protect the freedom of
speech with respect to Islam it does but
that protection has been forfeited it
was forfeited long ago because of the
tendency in the Muslim Community to
erupt with just Psychopathic rage in
response to what it perceives to be the
desecration of religious symbols and
that should be intolerable to us uh but
it's you know we have acquiesced to it
and the new Norm is there are certain
things you can't say about Islam there
certain symbols you can't traduce and um
it's because we know that tens of
thousands even hundreds of thousands of
people will will March into into the
streets even in the capitals of Europe
could you make me ask this could you
could you flip the argument the other
way too could some people would say that
the scale the disproportionate as many
see it scale of Israel's response is
motivated in some part again by a
religious motivation that some of the
more Hardline Ultra religious members of
netanyahu's cabinet really do want to
have some kind of genocidal war with the
Muslim Palestinians I mean does it work
both
ways well it does work both ways uh when
you're talking about a tiny minority of
Jews in Israel I mean the the ultra
Orthodox the settlers who the minority
of settlers who are motivated by their
their religious
fanaticism um yeah I think those those
those religious claims upon real estate
in the Middle East are are not justified
and they aren't in fact part of the
problem and so yes this the settlements
in the West Bank are certainly
provocative um and they you know they
should be disallowed right if we if we
were ever going to get to a two-state
solution part of the the the remedy
there is to disenfranchise the religious
Maniacs on the the Israeli side but as a
in terms of the scale of the problem it
is orders of magnitude smaller I mean
not just for that particular region but
for the whole world and we're talking
there 15 million Jews on Earth most of
them are impressively secular most
believe uh very little that would would
motivate a person to to want to die for
their religious
identity the real justification yeah I I
just on that I would just say I just
wonder whether you think that what is
going on now in Gaza the kind of
obliteration of a lot of Gaza the mass
killing of civilians and so on um which
Israel will justify by saying they're
trying to get rid of a terror group I
understand the thinking but the
execution has been so increasingly
indiscriminate that is there not a
danger that it actually massively
increases the radicalization problem
rather than remove
it
well there two two piece to that answer
what one is that the the the real
problem of
radicalization I would say is not
connected in any kind of rational way to
real world grievances right I mean so
the the real problem of radicalization
is the level is the level of ideas right
ideas around martyrdom and Jihad that
easily cross borders and as we saw with
the Islamic State uh can easily win
recruits from 100 countries I mean so
you literally have people who have no
discernable grievance against anyone I
mean you somebody dropping at a medical
school in London going to fight with the
Islamic State purely on the power of
certain ideas right so that's that's a a
larger problem of jihadism and specific
religious beliefs that are endemic to
Islam and that it is taboo to criticize
if you're if you're certainly if you're
a Muslim you certainly risk your life
and charges with charges of apostasy and
blasphemy if you criticize these ideas
but specifically with Gaza the the the
killing of innocence and Gaza is an
absolute tragedy and it's very easy to
understand why people seeing that
imagery think that um Israel is in the
wrong for producing so many casualties
but they are fighting a terrorist
organization a jihadist organization
that is using its own civilian
population as human Shields it has
strategically embedded itself among
civilians it it wears civilian clothing
right it's it it put its headquarters
under a hospital it it um prevents
civilians from leaving to safer areas
because it wants to produce Carnage
because Carnage is an advantage in in
this PR war against Israel and frankly
these people sincerely believe in
Paradise they think that good Muslims
are going to go to paradise where
wherever they die however they die and
so there there is in fact no problem
with the with this Carnage right and
that's that's the thing that is is very
difficult for secular people to get
their heads around that people actually
believe these things when members of AAS
chant we love death more than the Jews
love life that is a sincere expression
of their worldview right it's not
propaganda it's not posturing it is a a
a confession of a psychological state of
mind and of a worldview and we we doubt
that at our Peril right I mean this is
this is the issue we're dealing with a
suicidal death cult that doesn't care
about its own civilian Cas casualties in
fact its own civilian casualties are are
are an additional advantage for it Sam
Harris great to talk to you again I
really appreciate you coming on and
speaking with such clarity about a
complex issue thank you very
much